- [Instructor] Let's say
that we have two populations.
So that's the first population,
and this is the second
population right over here.
And we are going to think about
the means of these populations.
So let's say this first population
is a population of golden retrievers
and this second population is
a population of chihuahuas.
And the mean that we're
going to think about
is maybe the mean weight.
So mu one would be the true mean weight
of the population of golden retrievers.
And mu two would be the true mean weight
of the population of chihuahuas.
Now what we want to think about is
what is the difference between
these two population means,
between these two population parameters.
Well, if we don't know this, all we can do
is try to estimate it and maybe construct
some type of confidence interval.
And that's what we're going
to talk about in this video.
So how do we go about doing it?
Well, we've seen this, or
similar things, before.
What you would do is
you would take a sample
from both populations.
So from population one
here, I would take a sample
of size n sub one.
And from that, I can
calculate a sample mean.
So this is a statistic that
is trying to estimate that.
And I can also calculate a
sample standard deviation.
And I can do the same thing in
the population of chihuahuas,
if that's what our
population two is all about.
So I could take a sample,
and actually this sample
does not have to be the same
as n one, so I'll call it n sub two.
It could be, but doesn't have to be.
And from that, I can
calculate a sample mean,
x bar sub two, and a
sample standard deviation.
So now, assuming that our
conditions for inference are met,
and we've talked about those before.
We have the random condition,
we have the normal condition,
we have the independence condition.
Assuming those conditions are met,
and we talk about those
in other videos for means,
let's think about how we can construct
a confidence interval.
And so you might say,
alright, well that would be
the difference of my sample means,
x bar sub one minus x bar sub two,
plus or minus some z value,
times my standard deviation,
times the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the difference of the sample means.
So x bar sub one minus x bar sub two.
And you might say, well,
where do I get my z from?
Well, our confidence level
would determine that.
Confidence, confidence level.
If our confidence level is 95%,
that would determine our z.
Now this would not be incorrect,
but we face a problem,
because we are going to need to estimate
what the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the difference between
our sample means actually is.
To make that clear, let
me write it this way.
So the variance of the
sampling distribution
of the difference of our sample means
is going to be equal to the variance
of the sampling distribution
of sample mean one,
plus the variance of the
sampling distribution
of sample mean two.
Now if we knew the true
underlying standard deviations
of this population and this population,
then we could actually come up with these.
In that case, this right over here
would be equal to the
variance of the population
of population one, divided
by our sample size, n one
plus, plus
the variance of the
underlying population two
divided by this sample size.
But we don't know these variances,
and so we try to estimate them.
So we estimate them with our
sample standard deviations.
So we say this is going to
be approximately equal to
our first sample standard
deviation squared
over n one plus our second
sample standard deviation squared
over n two.
And so we can say that an
estimate of the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the difference
between our sample means and estimate
is going to be equal to
the square root of this.
It's going to be approximately equal to
the square root of s
one squared over n one
plus s two squared over n two.
But the problem is is
once we use this estimate
that we can figure out, a critical z value
isn't going to be as good
as a critical t value.
So instead, you would say
my confidence interval
is going to be x bar sub
one minus x bar sub two
plus or minus a critical t value,
instead of a z value.
Because that works better
when you are estimating
standard deviation of
the sampling distribution
of the difference
between the sample means.
And so you have t star
times our estimate of this
which is going to be
equal to the square root
of s sub one squared over n one
plus s sub two squared over n two.
And then you might say, well,
what determines our t star?
Well once again, you would
look it up on a table
using your confidence level.
And you might be saying, wait, hold on,
when I look up a t
value, I don't just care
about a confidence
level, I also care about
degrees of freedom.
What is going to be the degrees of freedom
in this situation?
Well, there's a simple answer
and a complicated answer.
Once we think about the
difference of means,
there's fairly sophisticated formulas
that computers can use to get
a more precise degrees of freedom.
But what you will typical
see in a statistics class
is a conservative view
of degrees of freedom,
where you take the lower
of n one and n two,
and you subtract one from that.
So the degrees of freedom here,
so the degrees of freedom
here is going to be
the lower, lower of n one minus one,
or n two minus one.
Or you take the lower of n one or n two
and you subtract one from that.
In future videos, we will
work through examples
that do this.